hey what's going on guys it's jake here
and today after 100 hours almost of
gameplay
in eldon ring on my main account here i
think i've finally made
what i think to believe the best
dexterity build that you can possibly
have in the game i'm sure there's other
micro managing levels that i could have
put in
or memory slots that i could have
unlocked to make these weapons even
better in my opinion
this is the most fun i've been having a
freaking blast on new game plus just
flying through the game with this build
in particular and i think you would have
a lot of fun with it too so let's start
by looking at our stats so i'm a very
high level level 190 which is way higher
than uh the base needed level of what i
would say would be about maybe 100 to
120 level to beat the main game in all
bosses in the normal playthrough so not
new game plus i would just recommend to
you to be level 100 to 120 if you want
to beat the entire game so this is big
dick swanging i
i have always called all of my
characters and all of these souls games
i've always named a big dick swank i
don't know why i just i just think it's
funny level 190 which is you know uh i
would recommend for new game plus
actually for you to be uh probably
around this around 190 probably 175 if
i'm shooting low for you to uh beat the
game on new game plus melania which i
believe to be the final boss of the game
was ridiculously hard even with a mimic
and everything like that to beat melania
on new game plus she just does so much
damage and everything like that but
let's talk about our normal attribute
point uh allocations that i chose to put
onto this build you can always go to the
grand library talk to the queen you can
reallocate your points to whatever you
want guess it sort of depends on your
starting build but it really doesn't
matter you you will get what you want
uh if you just level up enough you
really don't have to worry about it so
for vigor uh with just normal attack
rating vigor like health points in the
game the soft cap for elden ring is 40
and then the next soft cap after that is
60. so i just said well i might as well
max out on a dexterity build my bigger
points are my health overall health at
60 because if you go higher or even
lower than that all the way down to 40
it really doesn't make that big of a
difference but once you hit 60 that's
where it starts to make the difference
when it comes to mind i just want to
have the fp points to do the weapon art
uh that i just love so much from melania
that you get
this just spamming your ass of war
you basically get her entire weapon art
which is just so freaking cool to me i
love it i love
melting uh enemies in this game with it
it's just a lot of fun so mind is just
for the fp points to be able to do that
a lot if i want to i also
use a another katana that we'll get into
all this in a little bit but i use the
nakakibi nakakiba i can definitely level
up the katana a bit more than i do right
now it's only a plus two so that's kind
of my next goal um just having this as
an option with a dexterity build is
really really nice uh because it has
this slash that just staggers and cuts
through people
pretty quickly it's probably good in pvp
especially melania's uh swiping around
and those giant circle slashes is just
so much fun to do you can switch back
and forth
pretty easily in this game so mine
pretty much goes into the weapon arts
that i want to do for the two weapons
that i chose on this dexterity build
obviously you want a lot of endurance to
do all these things fp won't matter if
you don't have the endurance to pull off
the entire move let's say i'm doing
melania's ash of war if i don't have the
stamina to go through this entire
moveset
it'll just stop it it won't complete the
entire ash of war if you don't
have the stamina to do so which is why i
allocated a solid amount of endurance
into 50 which is
soft capped at 50 just for base points
if you have talismans that increase your
uh your stamina it will cap at 60. so
this medallion greatly increases my
maximum stamina which takes it to 60 so
we're pretty much decked out on that if
i increase it any more than that it just
won't matter at all for this build
strength doesn't matter because we're
just trying to cut through people as
much as possible with these weapons that
scale
much better with dexterity instead of
strength for strength it goes 20 55 and
then 80. so if you're going for a full
strength build you can go all the way up
to 80 and that's the hard cap so
obviously this is a dexterity build we
are going hard on dexterity which is why
it's all the way at 80 which is the hard
cap for dexterity it is 20 55 and then
80 just like strength sends a dexterity
build we want to cut through people as
fast as we possibly can so that's why we
have that hard capped at 80 intelligence
faith and arcane just do not matter for
a dexterity build obviously you can
change this up like maybe you'll just
allocate your vigor points into faith so
that you can do
even cooler memory slots like you can
really mix up this build in a lot of
different ways i just found this one for
me to be the most fun let's talk about
our equipment and our armor really quick
so obviously we're using the hand of
melania at plus 10. it's the normal like
just using the somber
smithing stones to get it all the way to
plus 10 then you need the summer ancient
dragon smithing stone to finally finish
it off but this is the final physical
stats of 359 let's cut to us just
ripping up a mob of enemies in the game
i think that would be fun to see but
we're gonna just get it off
it's just so cool man it's so much fun
the bass attacks are extremely strong as
well
um another thing that i'll point out for
you guys is that i am using melania's
great rune this great rune allows me to
gain hp back after
successive attacks on an enemy so as i'm
slicing through that group of people i
am gradually increasing my
my health
just by hitting them a few times like
that's the hardest part about melania's
boss fight is that if she hits you she
gains a good amount of health back so
it's kind of cool that we can sort of
role play as her just kind of in our own
way going off of that as well i am using
talismans that help me gain more hp back
as i'm burning through them with all of
these successive attacks so i'm using
the taker's cameo which restores my hp
upon defeating enemies that's pretty
basic like if i kill somebody i want
held back just like from hitting them i
get health back as well seems like a
no-brainer that we should have this on
for this type of build we also have a
talisman that just adds on to our great
rune with successive attacks restores hp
it's pretty much what the great rune
does we're basically playing this game
like bloodborne at this point it's just
absolutely incredible we are using the
stamina medallion the viridian amber
medallion at plus one because we got it
in new game plus i also have the normal
one you can be using that uh but this
greatly raises my maximum stamina and
then for the final one enhances final
hit of chain attacks just to do a little
bit more damage because obviously
melania's weapon art is all
chain attacks it the entire motion of it
is chain attacks so getting that final
hit of it just does more damage goes
through shields whatever it is it just
makes our builds so freaking powerful
man it is awesome when it comes to the
armor i think armor is all about fashion
it's all about what you really want to
see in your build i personally love
blades i think that's how you say it
ballad blade however you say his name i
love his fit his his outfit is awesome i
think it really goes well with the
dexterity build i'm like this lone wolf
assassin going out and just absolutely
cutting through armies of people it's
just a lot of fun to me when it comes to
the armor obviously you can go with
whatever you want if you want melania's
armor you can buy it at the finger table
at the round table from the finger lady
excuse me where you can get her whole
outfit
i don't know the how much it costs for
the runes i'm sure it's around like 20
to 50 000 runes by this point in the
game you already have well enough to
afford that so you can wear that if you
want if you just want to do a full
melania rp run you can you can do that
man i love these games for that you can
role play so many different things for
my offhand weapon which is again the
nagakiba it's only at plus two i'm gonna
go and upgrade this all the way to plus
10. i really just like it for the weapon
art that it does it just melts through
people it cuts them up it staggers them
slightly and when i'm just two handing
it i think it just matches the dual
katana like long dual katana that i'm
going for with this wolf guy and again i
can just switch between them really
easily like left hand right hand dual
hand is just easy by holding y and then
whatever hand you want to go to with the
uh bumpers like that guy is a powerful
enemy in new game plus and we just cut
through them really easily while gaining
hp back if i took any hits
but yeah i definitely need to upgrade my
naga kiba to uh plus 10 for sure
at that point i think it will complete
the build with almost 100 hours in the
game at this point i cannot recommend
this game enough there's so many
different types of builds you can go
through i've been every boss in the game
i even looked up a guide to make sure i
didn't miss any bosses this game is
absolutely incredible everyone should be
playing this game if you can afford to
do so
it is one of the best games ever made
but for me this is my dexterity build at
100 hours i really hope you guys enjoyed
the video hope it helps a little bit so
you know how to like where to allocate
your points or where you can get certain
weapons uh if you want to know just let
me know i can make videos on that or
short videos or just answer you in the
comments totally up to you thank you for
watching guys i love eldon ring i'm glad
you're enjoying it as well if you're
watching this video
and i'll see you all in the next one oh
and again let me know what you guys want
to see i'm looking for ideas of what
videos i want to make and just starting
my channel out trying to grow trying to
get to a thousand subs so that we can
start making some money here on youtube
that'd be great so have a great day
everyone see you in the next one peace
out